[Music]
foreign
and I am teaching me it's not just code
managing an open source project at
posacomp2023 I am super excited about
this workshop and I want to tell you the
top three reasons you should come to
this Workshop the first is right there
in the name it's not just code we have a
lot of great things at fazicomp a lot of
them are around code but if you've
worked on an open source project you've
noticed that some of the things that are
hard are really not about the code but
about collaboration and project
management and governance and those are
things that we can learn too you just
usually haven't had an opportunity to
learn them yet so this is a place where
you can learn about those other pieces
of the projects that aren't the code
the second is templates yes templates
that thing that you're trying to do
other people have done it before so you
don't need to do it all on your own and
in this Workshop I'm going to give you
templates and workflows and checklists
that you can adapt for your project and
get started with right away whether your
project is big or small just starting
out has been there a while you founded
the project or you're coming in new and
want to contribute
these pieces will help you no matter
where you are and finally the third is
community uh so this is an opportunity
to come together with other like-minded
folks uh if you're in this place in a
project it can feel a little bit lonely
you know maybe don't have somebody else
to talk to you're not sure if the things
that you think are hard are just hard
overall or something that you feel like
you're not good at this is a place where
you can talk to other people about
shared challenges build some networks or
community and have these kinds of
connections with people that are things
that you can talk about going forward or
even just in the workshop so I hope to
see you there I hope I'm so excited
about all the things that we'll get to
talk about in this workshop and the ways
that they are going to make your life as
a maintainer a manager or anyone
involved in an open source project
better and more sustainable hope to see
you there
[Music]